welcome back to here and now everyone
tonight the story of a business
relationship that's forming between this
province and Greenland it's based on the
promise in Greenland's growing offshore
oil industry this week delegations from
Greenland are in the province talking
about the possibility of airline links
and other business relationships here in
aus Marie wad'n has been in Greenland to
find out about the excitement and the
opportunity here's part one of the
Greenland story so the cable comes
through comes down underneath the the
water it's buried underneath the beach
underneath this old railway track and up
into the belly of the building a fiber
optic cable unwound 1,800 kilometers
away in Greenland has come to rest here
in Milton Trinity Bay now there's a
powerful broadband connecting Greenland
with computers in the rest of north
america the world's largest and coldest
Island is preparing for a new future
Greenland is so large it could almost be
a continent the majority of people are
Inuit 56,000 people in all scattered in
tiny isolated places where the main
business has always been hunting and
fishing that's no longer enough
nope Greenland's capital has 15,000
people many more are expected Anika
Henrickson is with nook tourism I used
to go out here and my snowmobile just to
relax and enjoy the peace around me and
the nature and and now you can see
there's a an entire small city out here
it has yeah it's only for the past eight
years all this building has come up
Greenland is getting into the offshore
oil and gas business this past summer
two rigs hired by care and energy of
Scotland explore the ocean off
Greenland's west coast this summer
almost all the major oil companies will
be doing the same Greenland is preparing
for an oil boom and so are people in
this province Sean Skinner is
newfoundland and labrador's Natural
Resources Minister there is going to be
a boom there and it is going to be
related to natural resources and I think
the immediate potential beneficiaries
can be our service and supply companies
in the offshore oil and gas industry in
October a chartered plane took off from
goose bay and in less than two hours
landed in nook Sean Skinner was on board
so was premier Kathy Dunderdale and
members of the Newfoundland oil industry
association Skinner said Labradors
proximity to Greenland makes it ideal
for flying in workers and supplies some
of it will happen on the ground in
Greenland but some of it I think canals
will happen in Labrador and could for
instance happen in happy valley-goose
Bay because of the short ride that
should have to take on a plane you could
house or stage what you need to stage in
happy valley-goose Bay and then just pop
the people across a short flight an hour
and a half or so and there in Greenland
they could be working
it was Jeff Howard as st. John's
businessman who helped green land land
its fiber optic cable here now he's
making it his business to connect
Newfoundland and Labrador companies with
their counterparts in Greenland we were
Greenland in the 1970s the parallels are
ominous and and we have the lessons
learned and that's what I speak about
when I speak at conferences in Greenland
here where the lessons learned you know
use our lessons and apply them get ahead
of the curve but not everyone agrees
that an offshore oil industry will be
good for Greenland coming up the price
of independence and will it come at the
expense of the environment we are not
really ready for climate change
you